not a good time sheldon but it's really
important
i figured out why the violin worked for
einstein and not for me
i need to become a jewish person
[Music]
sorry i'm late shalom
what's on your head a yamaha are you on
yama what
it's a special jewish hat it reminds the
wearer that god is always over you
mom come on it's funny it's not funny
and it's not a yarmulke
it is a coaster i crocheted at bible
camp
are you gonna say something to him
normally i would but i got bigger
problems right now
let's just say grace hold on are these
hot dogs kosher
over the next few days i continued to
play the violin
in an effort to replicate the mental
prowess of einstein
i was asked to confine my practice to
the garage by my father
mother sister and brother meemaw was
fine with me practicing in the house
but why would she care she doesn't live
with us
temple judea how can i help you hello
i'd like to become
jewish who would be in charge of that
how old are you
i'm 10. please hold
hello this is rabbi schneiderman to whom
am i speaking
hello this is sheldon cooper hello
sheldon
um how can i help you i'm currently a
baptist and i'd like to convert to
judaism
a baptist named sheldon okay
and why do you want to convert very
simple it's my intention to become a
great scientist and i couldn't help but
notice most of the great scientists are
jewish
so logic dictates it's time to switch
teams
well i'm sure there are many baptist
scientists you could emulate that's kind
of you to say but other than cornelius
dribble in the 1500s it's pretty slim
pickings
well sheldon you sound like a very smart
young man oh you have no idea
can i ask how your parents feel about
this well when i presented them with my
plan
the words over my dead body were used
i'm not surprised but they were
similarly resistant when i wanted to get
an ant farm and eventually they came
around
all right here's what i'm going to tell
you to do
read your bible already did cover to
cover
really quiz me no that's okay
i believe you all right
my advice to you is to stay with the
faith of your parents
what else you got okay then i'm going to
tell you
to be your own man but i want to be a
great scientist like albert einstein
sheldon when your days are over
god will never ask you why weren't you
einstein
but he might ask you
why weren't you sheldon
dab mom
yeah shelly i just thought you should
know
i'm not going to be jewish i'm going to
remain the atheist baptist you've come
to love
good to hear are you crying
yeah but don't worry everything's okay
good
[Music]
once again i brought my mother so much
joy she was moved to tears
i don't know how i do it
you